When we combine like terms, we combine
the coefficients of the like terms but
leave the variables alone.
Coefficients are numbers
used to multiply variables.
For example in the expression
five X minus two.
Five is a coefficient.
The two,
which does not have a variable with it.
is a constant.
Constants are numbers that don't
have variables attached to them.
That is they aren't
multipliers of variables.
X is the only variable here.
In calculating the cost
of the pineapples.
We saw that 7X+10X=7+10, all times X.
When we add up what's in
the parentheses, we get 17X.
The Coefficients 7 and
10 were combined and
the variable X stayed the same.
You should be aware that
if you are told to simplify
an expression with like terms that means
you should combine the like terms.
Simplify 4x squared minus 2x squared and
enter your answer in this box.